so I'm gonna be talking about
neurophysiology data today in case you
were worried I was gonna talk about MRI
stuff this is a last neurophysiology
experiment we did in my lab in about
2000 well from maybe 2010 to about 2013
we collected this enormous data set and
we've been processing it ever since and
hopefully we'll have a paper out on this
soon and this is talk all about this
specific visual area here on the lateral
sort of ventral lateral yeah surface of
the macaque brain well and the macaque
it's kind of runs up the whole side but
in the human this would be the better
level surface which is called area v4 so
you guys all remember that the primate
visual system is consists of many many
distinct visual areas and the macaque
monkey this map which was made in the
ancient days of about the 1990s had
about 32 macaque visual areas depending
on how you count the in for a temporal
cortex there may be as many as 40
different visual areas and then kack in
humans there are all of those visual
areas plus a bunch of others there's
probably 50 or 60 individual visual
areas in the human and all of these do
something complicated and they're all
wired together in this complicated
hierarchical parallel network and any
one of these visual areas has about a
50% chance of being connected not only
the other visual area but basically
every single area in the brain that
brain is a highly interconnected
parallel hierarchical recurrent Network
now I'm particularly interested in this
area v4 which as you can see is sort of
an intermediate area in what is known as
the ventral stream you may recall that
the cartoon version of the primate
visual system is that there's a dorsal
stream that does sort of where related
stuff which is mostly about coordinate
transformations related to getting the
information from your retinal coordinate
system down to your hand coordinates
that you can use to pick up objects
that's the dorsal stream that runs up
the back of the head and then there's a
ventral stream that's involved in object
recognition of course that's an
artificial distinction because these two
streams as you can see from this map are
incredibly
you know connected and work together all
the time but I'm interested in one
particular intermediate visual area
before why yeah it's complicated enough
to be interesting but stupid enough to
be tractable that's why I view it as an
optimization problem
what visual area can you study that is
interesting but you have a hope so when
I started this in David an essence lab
in the early 90s I thought it would only
take a small amount of time to solve
before and what I discovered was it has
taken a lot longer and you may not be
happy with our solution but we'll see
now of course why just to mention
quickly something you probably all know
you might ask why are those or since our
hierarchy of visual areas you probably
are all familiar with now the work in
deep networks that shows that if you
build a supervised learning algorithm
based on neural networks artificial
neural networks and train it to do image
classification you end up with a deep
network of say five or seven or as many
as 150 depending on how you want to
build your network different layers and
these things do a pretty good job of
image classification if you go into the
intermediate levels of these networks
you can see that the receptive fields
the tuning properties of the artificial
neurons become increasingly complicated
and you can use one of these deep
networks like the cafe network to map
onto in this case MRI data this is the
visual system in the back of the head
and these white things are the
individual visual areas these white
lines v1 v2 v3 v4 and so on and it turns
out there's a shift from the early
visual areas representing really early
levels of the sorry the features that
best fit voxels in the early visual
system respond reside at early levels of
this network and the features that best
explain voxels the highest level of the
visual system respond in the higher
levels of this network that means that
before this intermediate visual area
probably contains neurons that have
features that correspond to intermediate
levels of this neural network so one way
you could try to solve before is do
exactly the same game that we did with
MRI data with neurons I could take this
cafe network and I could use the
individual cells that trained units as
features and fit them to neural data and
try to build try to solve the problem
that way
that might be hard because these
networks tend to be pretty difficult to
interpret let me give you a little
background about what we know from v4
about from classical physiology this is
kind of the first sort of interesting
study of v4 that didn't have to do with
color before was first identified as a
color selective area and later on we
realized it was a pattern selective area
and this is an awesome paper that was
particularly awesome because this is the
paper got me a job and it we found that
cells in v4 were tuned for these
complicated non Cartesian basis like
these hyperbolic basis functions and
these polar basis functions at the time
we did this experiment it was all
related to lead group theory and image
transformations and all that but these
weird patterns of selectivity for polar
and hyperbolic patterns probably have
nothing to do with anything
in mathematical interesting likely
groups they have to do with higher order
shape features being represented in this
area and if you take elements of higher
order shapes like a little contour
elements you can find that v4 neurons
are will be tuned for little subsets of
complicated contours this is a work from
Ed Conner here's a nice study did using
a genetic algorithm to try to do
gradient descent down all little shape
elements you could produce and trying to
find shapes that v4 neuron preferred so
it's a they're complicated little edge
shapes if you give a person a lesion in
their v4 you find that they can
discriminate moving it's just fine they
can discriminate orientation just fine
they can discriminate direction just
fine there's two things they can't do
they can't discriminate the orientation
of an am border an amplitude modulated
border caused by a phase shift and they
are lousy at discriminating curvature
contour curvature so again it seems like
v4 is representing some sort of
higher-order features maybe curvature
features maybe other kinds of features
and it also has this non-linear property
that am kind of borders seem to be maybe
special and I should mention that Kurt
Baker has done some nice work over the
years showing that neurons in area V two
neurons in area v1 don't respond to the
let's see the carrier in the modulator
they don't respond to the modulator
and AM signal by b2 neurons do so until
recently this was the best model of v4
out there and this model of v4 is the
stupidest model you could possibly
imagine it says okay a v4 neuron
basically has a tuning curve in the
power spectral space of the images and
if I take that power suit I measure the
power spectrum of the spike-triggered
average of my v4 neuron I can take a
bunch of images and calculate their
power spectrum and essentially dot it
with the receptive field and come up
with an ordering of images and
preferences for this before neuron and
this model which says that v4 neurons
only care about the power spectrum and
nothing else will explain I don't know
the correlation with the responses of
say point to something like that really
really bad
this model is basically useless it's
better than a simple and complex cell
model from v1 but barely so this is very
unsatisfying so in a long time ago now
because this person was in my lab for
many years Mike Oliver joined my lab and
he decided that we're really gonna try
to hit before as hard as we could with a
huge experiment involving way more data
than anybody had collected before and
then a hugely parametrized model with
way more parameters anybody collected
before and this took Mike like seven or
eight years to do he did all the work in
the project that I'll talk about and now
Mike did such an awesome job he's now at
the Dublin Institute basically
implementing deep learning models to
model the mouse data that the Alan is to
his collecting which has its own set of
issues
so we had to make a choice of beginning
this experiment do we want to use
classic simple stimuli like Mikan on
Cartesian gratings or red Connors little
shape le'ts or Romani whose natural
stimuli and of course my lab we always
use natural stimuli because I would
rather search through the stimulus space
that I know it's relevant then be
successful in a similar space that may
not be relevant so we use natural movies
for this experiment and then the problem
was how many natural movies should we
use and we took advantage of the Utah
ray technology so we implant this Utah
Ray in area v4 of the macaque and these
Utah Rays can record data for if you're
lucky three or four years and every day
you come in and you will end up with
signals on maybe about a third of these
Utah rays and you will end up with
somewhere between say one to four
sortable spikes now in a day you might
get thousand trials out of an animal
which might end up with giving you maybe
a couple thousand seconds worth of data
that's not really much data so if you
can only record from a neuron from a
single day you wouldn't really have
enough data to fit a sophisticated model
if you remember thinking back when you
took engineering at some point you can
model any system as a as any stationary
system it's a Taylor series and if it's
kind of memory you can models in a
Volterra series and if say you have a
fourth order system or a fifth order
system the amount of data you need to
characterize these higher-order
nonlinearities is proportional to the
non-linearity so as we move down the
visual stream and we end up going from
second-order models to third order
models to fourth order models we need
exponentially more data so we have to
have a way to get more data and to do
this we developed a method that was
independently discovered in Jim
DeCarlo's lab at MIT which Jim DeCarlo
came up with a good name for it called
the fingerprint method the idea is you
bring your animal into the lab every day
and you claim this movie this movie has
450 frames of video and so you play this
movie several times and you plot the
pair of stainless time histogram of the
neuron to this movie this is just the
spikes over time to the movie and now
when you bring the animal back tomorrow
because the Utah ray will have moved in
the neuro pill the brain will have moved
a little
that some tissue may have grown if you
look at the spikes if you look at the
waveform on the oscilloscope for a
neuron off your ATAR a it won't look the
same and you won't know it's in the same
neuron but if you then run this
fingerprint method the neuron will give
you exactly the same response and
because v4 neurons are coding in a very
high dimensional space every single
before neuron is different and they all
have their own individually unique
receptive fields and so you can
perfectly identify individual neurons
using this method so we use a
combination of the spike waveform in
these fingerprints and you can see that
this is one neuron we recorded for 37
days so we have single neurons that we
have three million frames of video on
and I have a simple rule in life if I
can't figure out what a neuron does
after a million frames of video I don't
care what that neuron does that's my
role so we have a lot of neurons we have
800 neurons with on order a million
frames of video and that means we might
really be able to do something so you
may recall I'm sure somebody talked
about this that 2b1 neurons look like
little Gabor filters in the classical
receptive field but as he pointed out
earlier that's this is a poor model of
v1 because this only explains the
classical receptive field and it doesn't
really explain all the non classical
surrounds and those are non classical
surrounds as a lot of people have shown
and natural movies have huge influences
on the cells responses so we need a
model that will be able to model this
and then on classical surround and and
that we need a model not only that will
model v1 and its response to the natural
movies but we want to have a model that
will model v2 and its response to
natural movies so Mike after a long time
came up with the following framework
which turned out to work great and be
very elegant I have as my input a movie
and I have a bunch of v1 neurons to look
like complex cells and a bunch of me1
neurons that look like simple cells but
any given b1 neuron is going to have a
simple cell in a core a complex cell
model or maybe a combination of the two
for its classic receptive field and a
bunch of these simple complex held
models for the non classical receptive
field that reflect the input to this
neuron and they may be delayed in time
so we have a framework basically using
deep networks but they're constrained 8
networks that implements this it's
called a deep time delay Network and
essentially the input to the deep type
this looks like a normal deep network
but the input is essentially a bunch of
simple and complex cell transformations
of the pixels that are spatially
localized and there are time delays so
the network doesn't only get this frame
like a normal deep network would get it
actually gets at each time step the past
history for say hundred milliseconds and
then the network can learn what
combination of simple and complex cells
it needs to at various time delays it
needs to accurately model the cell all
right now this v1 output goes into a v2
module and the v2 module turns out to be
exactly the same as the b1 input
except scaled up so essentially the
input to b2 is these pooling filters
these pooling filters look like complex
cells and simple cells except they're
operating on the rectified output of v1
and then these are pooled and sent to
the output okay so this you can think of
this model as a stacked v1 model there's
a v1 model the input goes into v1 does
whatever v1 does the output of that goes
into another v1 model that only differs
in terms of scale and that these
parameters are all fitt so this T deep
time delay Network has a lot of
parameters there's thousands and
thousands of thousands of parameters but
we have millions of frames of video and
we use very strict cross-validation
where we use a huge data set to fit the
model and we use a completely separate
data set of completely different natural
movies to test the model for each and
every individual neuron and I can talk
to more if you want to know more about
how this networks is designed you can
ask me Mike is I think the world's
expert at this point of fitting deep
networks which traditionally require
infinite amounts of data to very small
amounts of data like the responses to a
million frames of video that turns out
to be a hard problem for deep networks
and Mike came up with a bunch of tricks
to make these networks more efficient in
their design to basically lower the size
of them and to factorize various
parameters in order to reduce the
dimensionality of the input into the
network so that it could accurately
learn responsive one so the output is
the time response of one cell okay so so
these are the results for V 1 and V 2
mix
so this horizontal axis here is the
correlation we just use cuz every knows
what the correlation is between the
predicted response and the observed
response this is the number of neurons
because it's a histogram and the
traditional models of v1 and v2 if you
just have a simple and complex cell
model you'll end up with a big Gaussian
blob whose mode is around say 0.5 if you
take say a cafe network that was trained
on natural images and use the local
units of that network as parameters to
fit to your neural model you end up with
the blue distribution that network
actually works pretty well but if you
use Mike's hierarchical convolutional
energy model that's what he's calling it
you end up with this green distribution
and this green distribution although the
best sells the mode here is about 0.8
there were very very few cells to get up
to say 0.95 you might think well 0.8
isn't a very good correlation not to
spending all the variance but we're
explaining the responses of the cell in
16 millisecond time bins not explaining
the whole psdh average of 100
milliseconds we're explaining the
highest frequency we have available in
the data which is the video frequency 16
milliseconds and in 16 milliseconds
before a v1 through v4 neuron can give
somewhere between 0 and maybe 5 spikes
so the distributions of spikes in these
60 millisecond bins are not Gaussian
they're Poisson and if you're trying to
use correlation to characterize a
poisson spiking event then this is about
the word of base get the noise ceiling
we can't really wouldn't matter how much
more video we collected we can't really
predict these cells any better than we
are now this is the comparison of our
model which is on the vertical axis to
several popular models a neural network
versus model which is this blue thing
here the Nicole Rutz
model which is a good model and sorry I
don't know what's going up these little
squares and a convolutional sub sub unit
model produced recently by the vintage
and you can see in all three of these
cases our model works better than the
other model especially when we have a
lot of data so this model as far as I
know the best model out there right now
yes
the Colonel's in the network you're
fitting do they have a temporal
component is there purely spatial they
have temporal well they have an implicit
temporal component so they so basically
you have the spatial component at each
time lag so it's essentially kind of
like thinking like an F IR filter yes
yes so that's exactly since this thing
works so well one is there are thousands
and thousands of parameters oh what
happened it disappeared I'm sorry I
header on here there oh no it's coming
up I put on a different slide I'll tell
you about the parametrization just a
second yes somebody else has questions
yeah you're predicting single trial
responses or do you repeat the movies
and try to predict the average case oh
that's also a good question
so we're predicting single frame
responses where the response means the
average over repeats okay because that's
really the only thing you can predict
right if you're trying to predict a
single frame then you're essentially
trying to put a poisson number and your
noise ceiling will be very very low if
you're trying to predict the average
then your noise ceiling will be higher
so that gives us more Headroom right so
on every single one of these cells we
collect a fit set where the constraint
on your fit set for these kinds of
problems turns out not to be repeats it
turns out to be how much you sample the
parameter space so for the fit data set
you only do one repeat and you've
collect as many stimulus response pairs
as you can across all the stimuli for
the fit data set your constraint turns
out to be your noise ceiling which is
how close the thing you're trying to
predict is to the true population then
you should be trying to predict we only
have a sample mean so estimating that
sample to get that sample mean good you
have to use a lot of repeats so the
second one was the emulation said not to
fit centroid that yeah the second one
was the test set sorry yeah yeah sorry I
use yeah excuse me thank you for caching
these are a single self and b1 b2 yeah
so this thing works well this that's a
short answer for that alright now we
might have B for model I mean who cares
about b1 to b2
come on beat actually you know we don't
really know what the two does so that's
interesting too but we want to be for
Mom how are we gonna do that
well we stack we take the b1 model shove
it into a B to model the pool's shove it
into a v4 model of pools and in fact you
can tell where this is going the claim
of this is gonna be its v1 all the way
down it's just v1 v1 v1 v2 and v1 to
keep stacking v1 on top of each other
eventually you get face cells or
something so that's the idea so we've
got 3 B ones but this one's v4 so how
well does this work
oh here's the primer you can see the mob
that's why I move the parameters to see
this there's these v4 cells are big so
you need 172,000 pixels as the input you
have 26,000 parameters your fig may be
26,000 parameter seems like a lot but we
have a lot of experience fitting these
kinds of models now there is one trick
when you're fitting v4 which everybody
in the v4 field ignores and we did for
years and years and years to because
these are just an energy model yeah you
know sync complex cells kind of an
energy model and this is implement as a
compositional network so it's
convolutional and then it's hierarchical
so that's his name for right now we call
it actually we call it moly net in the
lab for my caliber net yeah essentially
right so so there's gonna be a bunch of
these units and they all have a
convolutional operate operation
associated with them they get half wave
rectified right and then so that's a
non-linearity and then they get fed into
a bunch of other convolutions and have
wave rectification x' the main
non-linearity here is this half wave
rectification so the top ones have the
energy in it yeah but these are fit
simultaneously so the algorithm picks
for a cell how many of these does it
need how many of these does it need what
their spatial frequency should be what
the orientation should be aware they
should be in the visual field so the
first thing we do is we have another
convergent method that finds the rough
receptive field of the cell and we cut
out area of the video three times the
size of the receptive field and and the
network is
to fit anything in there that it wants
so in that eetu box you're showing some
oriented filters but that's gonna be
learned
right there learned that's just like a
stand-in for whatever well in it they
have to be of this form so it's not just
learning it's not like a deep bow where
you can't learn anything
it has to the units have to be of this
form right just set this orientation
filters off of v2 is that's actually the
same as in v1 so that yes but now now
that that units that are the output on
which you have disoriented things they
are learned that's well understood there
is a huge library of these functions
that the system is allowed to select
from to combine them to combine learning
but the library is given the libraries
yes and it's a it's the same ones the
combinations that v1 that's produced yes
is trained end to end
yes yes yep just with that problem so so
so these you know that these v2 units
are going to be simple and complex cells
because they're constrained that's what
makes this different from a deep network
right this is a everything we know about
the functional architecture of the one
is built into this network right
including another trick that turns out
to be important so be full receptive
fields are big and they're so big that
they actually are not circular in the
visual field and that is because if you
remember v1 implements a log polar map
so there's there's a retina and you take
the log puller transform of the retina
and you end up with a huge folio
expansion and a peripheral compression
and if you imagine that this is your V
one map and you have a cell receiving
input from B 1 into V 4 but the
receptive field the anatomic receptive
field projecting onto V 1 is a circle
that means that that receptive field
will not be a circle in the visual field
it will be some weird egg shape and that
was a cool finding for observation first
made by Brad mater and it so you have to
include this log polar transform in the
input otherwise you don't get such good
predictions so that is actually built
into the model the WIPO transform is
stuck in at the very front end of this
model okay and these are the this is the
histogram for v4 now if your main
remember at v1 and v2 we're up here at
the noise ceiling v4 we're not at the
noise ceiling but if you notice the mode
here for v4 is a correlation of about
0.5 if you remember earlier in this talk
I mentioned that the classical model of
v1 predicts a correlation about 0.5 so
this v4 model works as well as the
classical model of v1 and people have
been saying for 30 years that we
understood b1 based on the classical
model of v1 so I'm going to assert we
understand before based on this
correlation coefficient and if you don't
like it go collect 10 million frames of
video because that's what you're gonna
need you might say why don't we have
better predictions here and I will tell
you these errors are not Gaussian or
prediction errors are not Gaussian and
that is because this these prediction
errors have a long tail so what happens
is most of the time these predictions
are pretty accurate but when this thing
fails it's because some specific image
came in that triggered some higher-order
non-linearity that we don't have in our
model because we don't have enough data
to fit it and the prediction and the
model go way off whack and so we end up
being way out in outer space and that of
course since this is a this correlation
is assuming Gaussian error and our error
is not Gaussian we sort of it looks like
we have more error than we have general
this works pretty well and the reason it
doesn't work is because he couldn't
sample the high order and nonlinearities
well enough because we don't have enough
data yes under predictions or over
predictions they can be anything yeah
Jack there's another reason maybe this
is it's a very tightly constrained model
right maybe a little constraint
is possibly the reason we think it's
maybe not over-constrained
is that if you remember back well i only
head up for the b1 b2 i have it for v4
but it's not in this slide deck we have
compared this constrained model to just
you know taking any standard
off-the-shelf deep network that's been
trained on natural movies or not natural
images and using those artificial units
as essentially features and finding
weights and then using that network so
that excuse me that network has a lot
more potential support and that network
does not work work very well but that
may be because it has too many
parameters so if we could if we could
take an infinitely large data set and
fit it to a train a neural network
trained on an infinitely large set of
data that you're right that might do
better okay so what do these things look
like really that's what we care about
what do they look like can I figure out
and kind of I have some intuition that'd
be wonderful it's a ugly Gabor wavelet
pyramid with with nonlinear interactions
in the surround what are these other
things like well let's look here's a
bunch of u1 cells and they look like v1
cells pretty much this board wavelet
couple really can wave at this one you
notice it's not good for wave it's a
little more complicated and you'll also
notice there's some subtle surround
going on here and these surround weights
even though they're all low they turn
out to be absolutely important for
predicting the response to the neuron
and if you don't have them you won't be
able to predict the response of this
cell as well all these cells are is it a
question yeah what are we seeing this is
just across time the receptor field yeah
yeah these receptive fields over time
because these are spatio-temporal
receptive fields sorry computed how no
no these are estimated back from the fit
model yeah I assume no no no I think I
think you're right I think he fed white
noise into the model yeah I think so
I wouldn't guarantee it but I think
that's what he did yeah yes
you get the ninth degree ship or not
yeah and in fact some of these moot
you'll see it'll move this ship's over
time I know if it's this one
but they'll ship they shift over both in
space and sometimes they'll get counter
phase in time they can be complicated
qualitatively these look kind of like
simple complex cells with surrounds and
they'd there's nothing that this model
reveals in v1 that you wouldn't have
expected from a more full than classic
you know
Campbell Robson view of a v1 I should
point out that all of these receptive
fields are at the phobia this is what
this had one cool side effect this study
when we put our first utah array in we
accidentally put it in the fovea so we
had phobia receptive fields these
receptive fields are like eight pixels
across and they're within a half the
degree of the fovea so this is the first
foveal awake monkey data that has been
reported and there's always been a long
question of how much do these foveal
neurons look like other phobia look like
other neurons kind of which was implicit
in bruce hawk and the answer is they
look like other neurons I mean they make
you know in general right so that's cool
now let's go to v2 here's the b2 neurons
and you can see these are bigger and
maybe a little bit more complicated this
one where you have some more
non-classical surround they seem oh yeah
it can also fit color you can see this
is a color selected v1 neuron there's
some color tuning in here they're not
hugely different and that's kind of
consistent with v2 data we have but then
we go to v4 and everything just falls
apart what is this very pronounced
crating structure coming from its lights
all the input are complex cells and
simple cells so the so the features the
right the basis functions that are being
fit in this model are complex cells and
simple cells and so they're gonna look
like gratings but you can have an
arbitrarily complicated selection of
grading going into your model and in
fact you know these tip these models
have somewhere between 7,000 and 20,000
parameters is being fit right so there's
a lot of gratings that could go in and
so you're just pulling out the most
prominent ones
but remember this model fits better than
anything else so envy it's well known
that be two cells you can model as
grading selectively just like be one
cells except they'll have other
nonlinear properties for example be two
cells which can be amplitude modulation
selective right for an am grading rather
than normal grading because of the
rectification I still don't understand
how you calculate these I mean you have
a hundred nonlinear system okay so ask
me later all right
I mean I only got I'm gonna get thrown
off the stage in two minutes here and
this is the interesting part here's
before right these receptive fields are
really ugly hideously complicated you
could not go home and tell your kids
what this what these receptive fields
are they're just really complicated
every v4 cell is its own special little
butterfly of hideous complexity they
makes no sense there's all kinds of
weird things in here and they're ugly
now I should point out also it's also
difficult to figure out what these
things are selected for so one thing
Mike did is he went through when he
found the movie clips that we know
objectively or activate the largest
response from v4 and then he essentially
fades that movie clip into the receptive
field so you can essentially see what it
is in the movie that the receptive field
is sensitive to and if you look over
here you'll see that this receptive
field is responding to this weird
segment of this octopus or something Gil
that happens to be inflating and
deflating over time and this receptive
field looks nothing like the feature out
of our million frames of video that most
activates this receptive field so
there's no way to look at these
receptive fields and figure out what
they're selected for in natural images
there's no way to look at the natural
image that elicited the large response
from the cell and figure out what it
wasn't that image that would have
elicited the large response it's just
complicated like didn't you have your
good ones that do a better job than the
bad ones they can't be all equal to me
no the good ones are they can be equally
inscrutable as what they can be right so
if you notice these these here's here's
this correlation is 0.65 and if you look
at the relationship between the
receptive field which looks hideously
complicated and and the image view
can you know once you squint for a while
you will find some relationship but it's
not always obvious these are complicated
intermediate units that you get by
pooling over successive levels and you
know my notion going into this because
on a classic I'm a classically trained
neurophysiology guys there will be some
representation in some basis that I can
interpret and that problem is that's not
true
so you can use the receptive field
complexity to say make a Division two
across your array from b1 to b2 that's
good you can see these all look like the
one neurons these all look like the two
neurons that's great
and then you can go through again just
like I showed you in a few minutes ago
and try to predict what the written best
stimulus is and what the best frame is
and try to look at the correspondence
here this is the v1 and v2 inputs to
this before neuron there this thing like
look at this this is a who's who the
hell wants to think about what this does
only a mother could love this this
filter this is just horrible
you're never gonna figure out what this
is and you look at the stimuli that
drive it's like oh god it's just
hopeless it's just hopeless
so how now we and now of course you know
if your physiologist thinking I got to
come up with cell classes I've got to
put these things together somehow that's
what we do that's what that's what a
good physiologist does I make classes of
plain neurons you can't make classes of
these things the parameter space is you
know there's 20,000 parameters and I'm
only got 800 miron's
so I can't really do any kind of cluster
analysis is gonna mean anything so in
that case we use the most powerful
computer we had Mike used his brain and
he squinted at these for a long time and
he decided there were four clusters
where clusters means I squinted and he
decided there were contour selective
cells color selective cells color
texture selective cells small feature
cells and large texture cells and this
was like a year ago and then he redid it
more recently and he came up with these
classes which are contour selective
cells curves you're selective cells
temporal contrast cells which you can
see change over time in a sort of on-off
push-pull kind of way and stripes
now these stripes are nearest class of
cells because you know you'll look
you'll notice these all look like am
filters they all look like a.m. where
the carry and the modulator at different
orientations in different frequencies
and different colors I'm done mostly
so so that's cool wait what is that
there one more come on come on you
beasts well I'll be done if I can't go
to the next slide so I should mention
that you can use these you can do an in
silico experiment once you have these
filters and replicate every observation
that anybody's ever made in v4 which is
handy so this is not a real v4 non
Cartesian Selective cell it's a fake V
for non Cartesian and selective cell and
if you show non Cartesian stimuli to
this cell you'll get the same tuning so
that's nice so this accounts for
classical results as well and this
relates to two interesting threads from
previous research one is this thing
called the scattering transform some of
you may know about from Stephane millat
that you can use for vision and another
is this cool paper from Karthik Kirkland
and Lewicki from 15 years ago where they
basically took Bruno's sparse coding
model and they stacked it on top of a
top of another sparse coding model and
they ended up getting receptive field
properties that look remarkably like the
ones that we see in this model and
that's it thanks very much I just want
to point out that that cool that the
ugly thing about this model is you can't
understand it the cool thing about the
model is you can't understand it because
what you can understand is the structure
right b1 goes into B one goes into be
one goes interview one that's really
easy and elegant and simple because we
know how to build a b1 so you know you
can build that figuring out what it does
is the hard part yes you're using clicks
what happens if you're playing your
prediction of randomized frames if you
we do have controls on the randomize
frames and if you randomize the frames
then the temporal kernel will do a
really poor job of producing the
responses what ends up happening if you
randomize frames is you've taken the
power spectra that temporal power
spectrum review whitened it and that
tends to linearize the responses of the
cell showing white stimuli to to a non
linear neuron tends to give you a linear
response because you don't have enough
nonlinear of the higher order terms to
extract the nonlinear features and so
what happen is all the nonlinear
components of the temporal response will
make poor predictions of that linearized
data just because you don't understand
what it's doing in simple terms doesn't
mean that it can't be understood in
simple terms right sure sure
I mean it but it depends on what you
want as simple right I don't I don't
think it's gonna be understood in simple
terms that we tend to think of in like
you know 1980s
you know neurophysiology but the
scattering transformer that that I think
is gonna be a hard sell because a lot of
these cells I mean they code textures
and boundaries
obviously because that's the stuff in
images but they do it in hideously
complicated ways that don't bear any
systematic and simple relationship to
specific textures and boundaries well
I'm good what do you complain about do
you think you could add some extra bells
and whistles that would of course I
don't know most past presentations of
all what more comprehensible relations
without making the focus any worse I
mean no
No except except for this poor guy who
spent ten years of his life basically
making it the best he could know other
than that I don't this is the lowest
parameter model we have that fits this
well so the Peter also asked about this
why don't we just use a neural network
we can train a deep network on natural
images or natural movies and then take
the learn units as features and find a
set of weights to map those features
onto my neurons response and you can do
that but a the thing actually won't work
as well at least right now as this and B
this is much lower dimensionality so if
we take a deep network and use it to fit
our data we need say a hundred thousand
parameters and this thing only needs
20,000 parameters one of the nice things
about this is a pretty low parameter
model considering what it does so you
know I'm not saying that there won't be
any intuition and Doris may be annoyed
because after all before is dumber than
I T right so shouldn't we be able to you
know if we can't understand before then
maybe we can understand IT which maybe
is why you asked that question but you
know it could be that there are modal
points in vision that are more
understandable than others right we are
animals that can pick out individual
simple features and we're animals that
can pick out objects because we're
designed to pick out objects but that
stuff in the middle we don't ever really
talked about that much nobody ever talks
about like this section of my head right
it said these intermediate areas of
weird contours and textures are not
something we have any conceptual access
to and it and and I so I think it's hard
for us as as animals that evolved to do
image image recognition to basically
look at these data and make any sense of
them I realized that there are more
questions pending but I think we should
[Applause]